what up space fam goes in here for anime
uproar in today I have a video that was
requested by a bunch of you I had so
many comments asking me to do how strong
is in Northgate that I had to make this
video next so far we have how strong is
tangible Zen it soo and Etsuko videos
and now here's the inner scale video if
you guys want to keep these videos
coming let me know by smashing that like
button if we have 4000 likes I will
start on the next one right away I love
doing these videos so I have no problem
making them for as long as you guys want
to see them on Instagram I've created a
story where you can vote for which
character moves on or GU I cover next so
make sure to follow us at anime uproar
on Instagram and vote on the story
ASAP since it will disappear after 24
hours I will link our Instagram in the
description and in a pin comment and I
will do these kinds of votes in the
future so make sure you're following us
there at anime uproar if you have to be
sure to subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you actually get
notified when future demon slayer videos
drop a quick warning there will be manga
spoilers in this video since we will be
looking at all of the evidence available
in order to figure out exactly how
strong in dose gate is now without
further ado let's jump into it enos key
is a manly man with a girly face
he's a very unconventional demon slayer
in the sense that he goes around
shirtless only wearing the lower half of
his uniform he is a dual wielder using
two swords rather than just one and as
we know from Zorro using multiple swords
is pretty dang cool he also wears a bore
mass that used to belong to his adoptive
Bor mother this has got to be a nod to
the Pokemon cubone who wears the skull
of its dead mom over its face now see
guys even anime directed premiere enlike
pokemon can get pretty dark anyways back
to demon slayer cubone enos Kaede didn't
have an easy upbringing you know Skye's
father was abusive and his caring mom
ran away from the dad and joined the
cult whose leader was upper moon too of
all people she eventually found out that
upper Moon to DOMA was eating his
followers and she tried to escape
DOMA eventually caught up and in a
last-ditch effort to save her baby son
she threw an auskey into a river from
the top of a huge cliff DOMA didn't
think that the baby would survive but he
did shrink Harrah's
enos k was from the very beginning keep
this in mind cuz this will pop up later
too
from that point on baby no ski survived
Tarzan style except he was taken in and
raised by wild boars rather than
gorillas he was with boars most of his
life before the file selection so you
could say he's a prodigy he developed a
breadth of the beasts file on his own
this is even more impressive when we
consider Daichi the breath of the Sun
user in the first breath user is the one
that created most of the other styles
for other people and then they pass
those styles on to their successors
meaning that eNOS K like the strongest
Demon Slayer yet ichi was able to
develop his own style and it's always a
good thing to be in the company of your
Ichi the most talented demon slayer in
history eNOS K passed the final
selection but he was off screen for that
arc
he actually acquired his blades by
fighting against demon hunters in this
way he also heard about the existence of
the demons and the final selection was
any to reveals that eNOS K was the
fastest person during the final
selection to go up and down the mountain
he finally pops up when tangent was
fighting the drumhouse demon you know
skate quickly shows that he is a
talented fighter on legs and to us to
pass out in order to defeat his demon he
knows K easily be heads his own demon
opponent then he beats the crap out of
savage - but to be fair Santa doesn't
fight back
however Tundra catches you know sky off
guard and breaks his bones nevertheless
he knows he can still fight with broken
bones funny enough all three tangent Oh
eNOS K and Sonny to have broken ribs but
eNOS K has the most an impressive four
broken ribs still though ton zero
struggles with him for tons at all
fighting in those keys like fighting a
four-legged Beast furthermore he notices
that eNOS key is insanely flexible
Janoski even pauses the fight to brag
about his flexibility time zero ends up
head butting in oski and though in those
case seems fine and eager to continue to
fight at first he eventually passes out
from a concussion however when he wakes
up he's ready to fight again right away
showing that he wasn't close to giving
it his all in this battle especially
since they weren't using their blades
during the spider family arc we get to
see eNOS k pushed much further he needs
to fight what appears to be the
physically strongest member of the
spider family the father spider demon
before the fight begins
tonzura makes it clear that eNOS K is
seriously hurt and he knows ke vain'
surged staggering from blood loss so we
should keep this in mind as we examine
this
by the father demon spider is so strong
that he lifts a tree sense control
blasting off like Team Rocket is
practically unaffected by sword attacks
and punch it or even mistakes and for
one of the 12 demon moons all this
happens before the demon demon
transforms into his more powerful form
in those key hits down on one blade with
the other and manages to do what tangent
of couldn't he cuts straight through the
demon's arm that's when the demon sheds
his skin and becomes bigger stronger and
much tougher
he knows Kay takes hits from the spider
gorilla but still manages to land a hit
on his neck the only problem is the
demon skin is so tough his sword breaks
the demon takes in Oscars neck into his
giant hand and before the demon crushes
the spinal cord in auskey his life
flashes before his eyes
luckily GU shows up and saves in escape
before the demon can kill him
interestingly enough gear requires more
slashes in order to kill the father
demon than he does in order to kill Rui
the actual demon moon despite almost
dying in no ski is okay enough to
appreciate gives amazing level of skill
he was able to cut through the tough
demon skin like it was tofu then GU ties
up in nosce because despite his injuries
in those case still wants to fight you
in order to prove that he's the
strongest you gotta respect this guy's
determination in addition to having a
hilarious dream where time gyros I need
to end as Zuko are all his underlings
during the demon train Ark we also seen
no ski chase someone out of his own
unconsciousness normally no one should
be in there unconscious area but in
Ostia is because he has a strong
consciousness enos K wakes up
explosively before saying to a tango qu
and helps protect the sleeping
passengers on the train using his Van
Cleave technique which is optimal when
you're surrounded by enemies in asti
eventually goes with ton 0 to defeat
lower moon one when tundra is about to
accidentally kill himself to wake
himself up because he thinks he's at a
dream it's actually no ski who tells him
it's reality and stops time zero from
killing himself in real life he knows K
and tons will work together to finally
cut the giant neck of the demon train
and finish off lower moon one lower moon
one as it's dying can help a comment on
how extraordinary in those case
intuition was when upper moon 3 akiza
shows up in no ski like tan zero is
nowhere near strong enough at this point
to fight him he knows he knows that he
do nothing but
the way if he jumped in to try and help
it in Goku but he does help rescue
people from the Train by the time of the
red light district dark Janoski
and zani 2 are strong enough together to
tag-team Upper Moon sex doc II since doc
II can turn her neck into a special
bending fabric they either need insane
speed to cut it off or they need to
slice it from two different directions
enos key is perfect for this because
he's a dual wheel there so Zane who
helps protect him as he knows he charges
straight for da key he uses his jagged
blades like a saw and succeeds in
beheading the demon he takes the head
and starts running away with it but
guitarra the stronger of the two demon
Mullins stabs Ennis K with his poisonous
blade what happened was he managed to
overpower the sound pillar and then
catch no stay and the others off-guard
q taro even says he stabbed an auskey in
his heart however at the crucial moment
he knows K comes and helps I need to cut
off duckís head he says don't
underestimate the suppleness of my body
shifting the positions of my organs is
just child's play and quote another
impressive skill that we can add to an
Oscars repertoire he also claims that
poison has no effect against the rugged
mountain boy like him
however desist to an extent in those
cave just talking big as he tends to do
and he's actually suffering severely
from the poison until medical helps him
with her flames still though he knows K
does recover from poison seven days
before tangina he is compared to a honey
badger who has a thick hide like armor
and is fine even when he fights much
stronger opponents like a lion poisonous
will work on it so it can even eat
poisonous snakes you know skin goes so
far as to call myself immortal which is
a stretch no pun intended but he
definitely does seem to have the most
impressive pain slash damage / poison
tolerance out of any non demon in other
words his ability to survive despite
what happens is extremely impressive
then there's in those case most
important fight to date which can best
help to illustrate what he's capable of
right now of course I'm referring to the
fight against upper moon - the second
strongest upper moon it is during this
bite daddy knows he finds out that the
upper moon to DOMA killed his mother he
drops on my favorite quotes when he says
to DOMA and I quote if hell doesn't
exist
I'll create it for you and quote during
this fight dolma is impressed at how he
knows he uses his sharply sensitive skin
to immediately sense the slightest chill
in the air he uses this ability to
escape from dolmas blood demon art which
were
Freeza no skis lungs otherwise still
though DOMA doesn't go full power
against eNOS Giancana he has his ice
clones fight that this doesn't mean in
Oscars week though remember that upper
moons are supposed to be stronger than
pillars and he knows he has to fight one
of the strongest ones with the help of
canal an on pillar herself against a
casa
tangelo had a pillars help namely gu and
against demon moon one the strongest
pillars had to team up together so the
idea that he knows cake could be DOMA
who is supposed to be stronger than a
casa on his own would have been
unthinkable rather we have to examine
what he manages to accomplish during a
seemingly unwinnable fight thankfully
help from a dead pillar eventually comes
in the form of Shindo blues poison DOMA
absorbs Nauvoo and all the poison she
was carrying in her blood and it finally
starts to take effect dolmas face begins
to melt like a witch in the rain this is
when the ice clothes begin to break and
in no ski and canal can focus on
attacking a weakened DOMA himself but
keep in mind a weakened DOMA is still
strong AF the upper moon creates a giant
bodhisattvas statue out of ice it covers
a large area with its long freezing air
however Carmel notices that the
technique is rough and lacks precision
although powerful it's a technique of
desperation Cano uses the epic
Vermillion eye technique to make
surrounding movements look slow and dull
this technique may cause her to go blind
because the pressure puts on her eyes
but she doesn't care she gets close
enough that starts cutting through the
demon's rotten neck but the freezing air
begins to step in her arm that's when
the star of this video comes in he uses
his most elegant Beast breathing
technique called sudden throwing strike
and senses blades flying towards DOMA
his blades pushing Tucanos giving her
the force she needs to cut through
dolmas neck this is one of the best
fights in the entire series hands down
Connell ends up losing her vision in one
eye to get her revenge
any nosce manages to get his revenge
against the demon for what he did to his
mother again
enos he proves to be crucial in
defeating a demon moon and this time
it's one of the strongest upper moons so
those are some of the notable things he
mostly has managed to accomplish up to
this point he's able to stay relevant
strength-wise along with Tanja ruins any
two demons and even upper moons have
consistently been impressed by an auskey
skills they've singled out his
extraordinary intuition his flexibility
and his sharp sensitivity to changes in
the air
he was born a prodigy who taught himself
to fight and still became stronger than
most demon hunters he continued to
progress and it's clear that he is no
longer that same in those gay who knew
he'd just get in the way if he fought
someone as strong as a casa
he fought DOMA who was stronger than a
casa was back then for sure and played a
crucial role in his defeat although he
obviously could not have done it alone
I'd argue that his ability to recover
quickly is the most impressive compared
to Sonny - and kanji I also think that
his power can still significantly
increase when his demon sailor mark
manifests however at the time being I
can't put him where time journal or zine
- are in terms of power
Tantra with this access to the
see-through world and new non self state
was able to overpower and unpause in
Icaza albeit it was only for a limited
period of time does that mean - on the
other hand being an upper moon
completely by himself
now Kakaako wasn't used to his powers
and he was upper Moon 6 but still this
was a truly impressive accomplishment so
far with the nosce we haven't seen him
shine on his own yes he played an
essential role in defeating upper moon
six stocky and upper moon - DOMA so we
can reasonably conclude that he is
extremely useful and effective in team
battles however I'd argue that Saints
who was the star of the daki fight and
Cana was the star in the DOMA fight and
he knows K more so play the supporting
role
don't get me wrong his role was vital
but he hasn't really gotten a chance to
be the star of the show against a really
strong opponent yet until that happens I
cannot put eNOS gate on Tundra dos or
even signing to his level yet still
though after the latest fight he knows
he has arguably deserved to be called
pillar level after all upper moons have
killed many pillars in the past any no
ski not only managed to survive against
multiple but he helped to beat them too
I can confidently conclude at this point
that he'd be a useful addition to any
future demon fight and I suspect that
he'll get his moment to shine sooner
rather than later and that is it for
today's video thank you so much for
watching I enjoyed making it and I got a
newfound appreciation for a nose Ches
hilarious personality he's arguably the
most entertaining character in the
entire manga if you liked this video and
want the series to continue make sure to
smash that like button to let me know as
soon as this video gets the 4000 likes I
will start on the next one ASAP if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and bring
that notification bell or else you'll
definitely miss the next video when it
comes out and don't forget to vote for
either gay or Moussa
via my Instagram story at anime uproar a
big thank you goes out to our patrons
over on patreon who help make videos
like this one possible I especially want
to thank our pro here to your patrons
the one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a
fan Jason Wilson king cell dressed angel
Cruz stealers poet Pablo
atropos rape $30 beat a garage Ian
Anatole Cassatt Sookie Lord a burg and
Matteo and are the one tear patrons the
ones who stay atop all clans Stephen in
Granada lo'laan autumn Matty Mac 239
makoto-kun and ya boy Seth if you enjoy
our work you can support more of it by
going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll get access to our
private patron only discord so check out
patreon accomplished anime our link in
the description if you're interested you
can also now join the YouTube channel
and support more content that way if you
prefer and until next time see you space
cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]